good morning John so in the last video
in which it was on your birthday I have
some footage of the demolition derby I'm
running into my tribal honor to drive ah
ah good night okay starting over again
from the beginning
good morning John that's how these
things start so in my last video that
wasn't your birthday I talked about the
County Fair and I mentioned the
demolition derby and there were all
these people in the comments who are
like demolition derby I thought those
were fictional ok I know that the heyday
of demolition derbies are long gone and
that there will no longer ever be a real
professional demolition derby circuit
but that doesn't mean that you guys
didn't know what the Malaysian derbies
are so I got very excited about the
possibility of introducing people to
demolition derby and that is what I
would like to do in my song today
I guess I'm excited why am i screaming
I've put on a nice shirt I'm about to
put on jacket so I can record the song
because you know demolition derby you
should be wearing nice clothes this
feels right yeah well we got a tickets
ready we're ready to go paid 2 bucks
extra to be in the front row so grab
your deep-fried cheeses and you
deep-fried Pete's beauty prodigies and
your deep fried sweet saw that mangled
metal and flaming exhausts worth every
dime no matter how much it cost you
there's a lot of good things about the
County Fair and Malaysia derbies why I'm
there well the demolition derbies got a
gun on demolition derby on that long
demolition
that guy just lost his tire
demolition-derby now I think he's on
fire
demolition derby is why I'm there
well a lot of old cars are ready to say
goodbye but we can't let a death panel
choose how they die with cash for
clunkers you get 4000 bucks for the much
more exciting ways to ditch your old
truck to strap you hauling on and dry
down your gears and take a shot of
whiskey and conquer your future there's
a lot of old ways to get rid of old cars
but then Derby is the best by far
yeah Dan Liston got it going on
demolition derby on that long
damn I mr. motocross intermission
demolition derby thank you back to
competition or the demolition derby is
why I'm there I got my glasses up on my
face screaming crowd anything this much
lunch shouldn't be allowed yawn nose to
nose and trunk the trunk nothing left
over but honks it junk yeah this is my
church and these are my prayers smashing
each other and flying through the air
one car left run not shed a single tear
demolition derby I'll see you next year
oh damn Alyssa derby I cover it it's
rusty demolition derby and your
radiators busted demolition derby you
thought you'd win the cash dealers do
Derby but you just got whiplash
demolition derby
I'll feel next year
[Music]
I wasn't very good but maybe it was just
good enough I was actually able to
collaboratively write this song using
etherpad could just write and everyone
can write on the same page and then I
started writing the song because I had
some of the verses already and then
people just filled stuff in it so
several of these lines are from
nerdfighters thank you very much through
the nerdfighters who are in the room I
would like to announce that this is not
Thomas continuing and that story
continues to be amazing and also that
there will be a truther fail going live
this Friday with John and Jory from the
microwave show is it a good idea to
microwave this
so hopefully you will enjoy that on
Friday I know I'm enjoying it just
editing it because those guys are
hilarious John thank you for being a
good brother and nerdfighters thank you
for being good nerdfighters I'm just
rambling now